[Music]
so
[Music]
it's one minute to midnight
and we need to act now
the prime minister's warning on climate
change to the biggest gathering of world
leaders ever assembled in the united
kingdom
but are they ready to deal with
humanity's greatest threat
this is the great debate
[Applause]
[Music]
getting to the heart of the issue
dominating the headlines tonight on the
great debate
climate change is bringing pressing new
threats to our way of life and security
around the world people are already
suffering devastating consequences some
nations warn they even face extinction
can global leaders meeting in glasgow
find a way to turn the tide and avert
disaster
our viewers panel drawn from across the
country and beyond
will share their views they'll have
their say
and they'll put their questions to our
studio guests
joining us this week mary robinson
former un climate envoy and human rights
commissioner who now leads the global
campaign for climate justice
plus richard walker the managing
director of iceland
foods chidi ochi obahara co-founder of
the cop26 climate action plan and an
activist from the direct action campaign
group extinction rebellion
and climate scientist dr ella gilbert
tonight the big question facing them all
about the climate crisis
is it already
too late
the world must wake up
quite literally it is the last chance
saloon ultimately
all of us will feel the impact some of
which are now unavoidable it's one
minute to midnight on that doomsday
clock build back better blah blah blah
we have to get everybody to do more
green economy blah blah blah it's gone
from being 35 degrees celsius to now
suddenly this absolutely torrential rain
this isn't normal
this is literally about the future of
the planet
i think it could be done
let's get straight to the wall let's go
to our viewers panel and i am going to
start with
tom rogers in london
tom
what's your view on this question
good evening trevor good evening panel
um my question is when will the
government get serious about climate
change
why have you any doubts about that tom
i have a few trevor so if you look at
the chancellor's budget speech last week
i think he talked for 70 minutes and
didn't mention climate once
here in the uk we have plans to build a
new coal mine amongst many other fossil
fuel projects and i don't see how we can
hold the likes of china and india to
account if we're planning coal mines of
our own
i don't think we're doing enough on
skills and jobs so if you look at the
government's net zero strategy it says
that we need to fit 600 000 heat pumps a
year there's nothing from the government
in terms of how we're going to develop
those skills
and develop people to do those heat
pumps and then finally i think most
concerning i've seen very little from
the government on how we protect people
on lower incomes this is going to be
expensive for people they're going to
have to change their cars change the way
they heat their homes make lifestyle
changes so i've got several doubts
okay i can see some support for that
from our viewers panel but let's first
come into the studio and
panels tom's question is
when will the government get serious
about
climate change
ella gilbert you
follow this closely
what's your answer
well as a climate scientist we've known
for
decades and decades that really
ambitious action is needed and the scale
of the climate problem
is huge and we've known that for years
and years and we've had lots and lots of
time for successive governments to
start to take actions to challenge the
the climate crisis and yet it's it
seemed to be quite difficult so far um
we have lots of kind of
rhetoric about governments taking
climate change seriously and
implementing targets and pledging to
make changes but then as tom says
sometimes
those
their actual actions don't necessarily
correlate with what they say they should
be
let me come to you mary robinson um
you follow this closely in fact you're
responsible
for monitoring a lot of the action here
um
we're talking about our government here
uk government
what's your rating on the british
government
the british government has done well in
some ways in its own ambitions vicious
targets on clean energy and on
net zero
but i do agree with the point that was
made by your questioner
uh a president of the cop has to give
exceptional leadership frankly because
it has to lead the other leaders
and
it is true that on
you know commitment on um cumbria oil uh
sorry cumbria coal or cambo the oil
field that in the north um sea um
these are not what a presidency should
be thinking of and also
the cuts in in in development aid
um you know and the fact that that's now
being extended in the recent um
budget of the chancellor
and the fact as as was mentioned you
know the chancellor's budget
uh hardly mentioned in fact it mentioned
net zero once it didn't mention climate
at all and we need governments that give
a leadership about being in a mindset of
crisis a mindset of crisis and we didn't
feel that even though the united kingdom
has done quite a lot in a good way as an
as a
you know an industrialized country okay
thank you richard walker
you're a business
person and you have to spend a lot of
time
worrying about what the government uh
what the framework the government sets
is
um are they doing as well as they ought
to
yeah i agree with uh what some of the
panelists have said because
i think they i think the chancellor in
his budget mentioned the word cider
more than he did climate in fact as mary
said he didn't mention climates at all
so um whilst the government is certainly
good about talking about climate change
what we now need as you said is a
framework
for the market to operate in now i'm a
capitalist um and generally in favor of
of less regulation but of course when we
have something as urgent and as
existential as climate change what we
need is more government intervention
more of a framework for the market to
operate in because quite frankly we
don't have time for the good companies
to rise to the top and for the bad
companies uh to be eliminated and
therefore what the government really
needs to face into now is thorny issues
that are tough to get past voters but
things like a carbon tax or a
consumption tax uh trying to get people
wean people off things like meats all of
these are very tricky issues and that
are going to be full of ambiguity and
nuance and uh quite frankly difficult
but you know if we're really serious and
if we really are one minute to midnight
that's what we're going to have to
start facing into and i suppose
ultimately what we need is a framework
for business where businesses compete on
how environmentally beneficial they are
and we tax things we don't want like
plastics and deforestation and pollution
and we don't tax things that we do want
like jobs okay
chichi
i have a horrible feeling that we're
going to have
uh the unusual situation where a
supportive extinction rebellion is going
to support a self-declared capitalist on
this
well thank you for the introduction
trevor and before my time in extinction
rebellion i actually work as an
investment banker in the city of london
so i think it's really important to
dispel this idea that extension
rebellion have an ideological bent we
don't we are focused on the climate
emergency and within the context of
answering tom's question this government
is having a challenging time trying to
clearly
show an action plan that gets us from
point a to point b
and crucially for example the government
came out last year with a 10-point plan
including and this is a key action point
in that plan a homes grant a green homes
grant which was supposed to help
insulate people's homes and supposed to
help them get a grant so that there
could be a just transition away from
where we currently are and away from
fuel poverty but what happened of course
was that that fell apart completely um
the green homes got was supposed to be
available until this month it was
cancelled in april and we know just for
the fact that kovit has interceded we
know for the fact that the government is
frequently distracted and does not
prioritize climate change we know that
the results that come out of this is a
feeling from the public that they're
being left behind they're not being
listened to but their democratic rights
aren't being supported we see
demonstration after demonstration that
isn't just extinction rebellion it's
hordes of young people but we're not
seeing legislative follow-up we're not
seeing acts that put this into place all
right um
we don't have anybody from the
government here but i suspect if they
were they would say
that
at paris there were only 30
percent of countries that had set
targets now there are 80 percent they
would say that the uk was the first
country to uh set a net zero target of
2050 uh and that actually use of coal
for example has been cut from 25 percent
of our energy needs to i think
i think it's now two or three percent uh
not for me to make the government's case
but uh we try to be as fair as we can on
this program so let me come to the wall
let's see the viewers panel uh those who
think the government could do better
yeah
that is pretty much everybody okay let
me go to um
i see jan adamson in camaron in wales
jan you you think the government ought
to be able to do better tell us why
yes i do i think that many people really
want to do something constructive to
stop this climate crisis
one of the best schemes was the feed-in
tariff for solar panels
that's a way for individual households
to be contributing
sustainable energy to the national grid
and instead in 2019 the government
pulled the plug on it so that no feed-in
tariff scheme operates with that
now instead we have the heat pump
initiative
and from my own research because i was
thinking about doing that myself
it doesn't work well in older houses
it doesn't work so well in the winter
it's expensive to install and people who
have had them put in are taking them out
because they cost so much electricity to
run
so i'm concerned that the most
vulnerable
will be left will be lumbered with an
effective system
jan thank you let's go to ash mukherjee
um
ash you have an unusual experience
you've actually spent some time in
antarctica seeing the impact of climate
change what's your view
i am very worried trevor and thank you
so much for that question uh what
worries me is that antarctica is the one
continent in the world that affects
everybody else living everywhere
it keeps our feet dry and it gives us
oxygen to breathe because of all the
plankton that grows under the ice in
antarctica which is halving at this
point
and it feeds crail that feed
whales which are fertilizers giant
fertilizers for the world's oceans they
feed richest freezers in every store in
iceland and that antarctic ice has
already melted by half over the last 40
years we can do the maths on how long
that ice is going to last okay i stay
there for a second um
it's so tempting and in a sort of tv pun
to come to you because he said i iceland
here richard but um there is a serious
point please here
is it
too late
have we gone too far
to rescue the situation
look um i i think it's it's easy to um
uh to be pessimistic of course because
you you look at the destruction all
around us um uh of the natural world
that we we love and and uh it's
seemingly a kind of daily occurrence now
uh
uh one 100-year events these uh biblical
um weather patterns that that were the
the thing of legend before so of course
it is very serious but i'm fueled by
optimism actually and i'm fueled by hope
because um i i see that
most of all uh citizens around the world
are rising up uh declaring climate
emergencies we've got kids striking from
schools taking action into their own
hands we do have businesses trying to do
better and
the gentleman is absolutely right
iceland is far from perfect iceland is
not even a sustainable business but we
are trying to do what we can where we
can and trying to do better and i don't
think there's really any business uh men
or women that uh
that don't want to try and uh do better
for the climate well
we've been talking about the role of
government and report cards not that
good uh but what action should we all be
taking that's next
i'd love to travel from london to
glasgow on a train not takes a day to be
honest air travel is one of the worst
place we can contribute to climate
change we're going to have to bring down
carbon emissions we have to spend money
12 big corporations that are producing
the overwhelming bulk of the world's
plastics i think we need to move away
from single-use anything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do they fear they'll be
killed
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside
we know that 800 000 people have been
displaced
i think experiencing the two million
person march in hong kong
that was the moment
[Applause]
[Music]
police have been foreign
[Music]
sky news bangkok
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're discussing the climate crisis and
asking is it already too late
i want to go back to our wall to our
viewers panel and i'm going to talk to
noctran
who is in nottingham good evening not
you've got a thought that you want to
share with us
uh yes i do uh i think i totally agree
that we do need to worry about the
climate change and because it is our
planet the the only planets we've got
and if we don't look after it we're
going to die we kill ourselves
and i think i'm grateful that we've got
amazing scientists who actually have
discovered all the changes that's
happening and also they are generally
offering all the options all the things
that we can do to make things better and
many people actually many were clapping
that means they do agree that we do want
to take actions is there a question you
want to put to our studio guests
i do i say that now is in crisis but
financial issues also a problem for all
of us is it fair to pressure people to
make like very expensive changes in
their lifestyles that they can't afford
just for the sake of climate change
thank you very much let's let's bring
that back into studio and let's talk to
our panel knox question is is it fair to
pressure people into making expensive
changes to their lifestyles
mary robinson
is that what you and all of the others
who are debating it in glasgow
what you're going to make us do
i think it's a good question because
the
steps we want to take
as individuals that are important have
to be affordable
we have to have affordable electricity
we have to have affordable uh ways of
keeping our houses warm we have to have
affordable transport this is really
important and i think governments have
to think governments need to be in
crisis mode and think what do we need to
do
they may have to spend some money in the
shorter term it's our children's money
and the reason i call it our children's
money it's the money for a safe future
so if we have to do things
to make sure
that going to clean energy is actually
affordable that just transition is paid
for that everything moves seamlessly
pushing with incentives in the direction
of clean energy that we don't subsidize
fossil fuel that we stop all the bad
things and move in direction of the good
things if we have to spend more money to
do it i'd spend it
chidi um is there a danger here that
you know everybody's on the side of
good and virtue but what they really
want is for somebody else to do it
it's a great question and it's about
balancing out rights and
responsibilities well it's true we all
have a responsibility to act in a
responsible way towards the the climate
we can have you know meat-free mondays
we can have fossil fuel free fridays
when we don't drive but we need to have
an overarching government system that
supports us if there's a system that you
know where you have to live within a
system where there's no public transport
you will have to use your car
if you live uh in a district where
recycling is impossible because there's
no recycling depot you won't be able to
recycle but all of this is about
balancing those well all of this is
basically saying we don't do anything
it's all down to that's not the white
hole no no i disagree with you i think
that we have to do as much as we
possibly can but the governments create
enabling environments so to talk a bit
more detail about the question you were
being asked just earlier on i mentioned
the green homes grant earlier on and 62
percent of the public said they were
going to take up this grant they wanted
to use it to affect the just transition
and move their heating systems from
gas-based ones to alternative renewable
energies but the government cut the
grant unannounced in april for no clear
reason now that that's an irresponsible
thing to do
by the government which causes people
themselves to act relatively
irresponsibly there's a chain of
causality that we can't ignore
all right let's go back to a war now i
want to talk to jackie skip
jackie how much of what has to be done
is down to government and how much is it
down to voluntary efforts by the average
person in the street or on the bus
um
yeah i've i find it really hard to be
positive about the future sometimes
i look at my three young grandchildren
and i wonder what sort of world any
children they have will inherit
um it's an effort that has to come from
all of us really to stand a chance of
saving our world
i think we should put pressure where we
can on businesses and governments
i would love to see more incentives for
green businesses and sanctions
sanctions for those that perform poorly
but i think personal responsibility and
setting an example to today's children
is going to make a huge difference
i think it's too easy to think as one
person we can't attract any change
alone we probably can't but if millions
of people just make one little change
we're going to see a massive difference
thank you joe absolutely
thank you jackie is that right that we
can all do something
i think absolutely and the ipcc the
internet governmental panel on climate
change recently report uh released this
landmark report and one of the most
important statements in it i think is
that every single ton of greenhouse
gases matters every single tenth of a
degree matters but also that means that
every single action that we can all take
matters whether that's the individual
whether that's the business whether
that's the government everything that we
can do
makes a difference and like the
questioners just said even though you
might feel like as one
solo person you can't make a huge
difference it's a drop in an ocean an
ocean's made up of many many drops so if
we all get together and all make those
changes and hope that you know you're
getting support from government
legislation you're getting support from
international negotiations you're
getting support from businesses if we
all do our bit everything that we can do
then we can affect change
yeah but is um
not to be too cynical about this but is
that really how people behave we tell
them everybody says you know you come on
telly and i do pregnant like this and we
tell everybody this is good for you and
everybody nods wisely and then they get
back in their car
now of course you've got to create the
enabling environment as judy was saying
to make those decisions easy to make it
easy to say okay instead of getting um a
flight to scotland i'm going to take the
train it has to be cheaper or easier or
both and it's about having a kind of a
wholesale system change that means that
those decisions are
you know the obvious decision to make
rather than necessarily having to rely
on people being you know
good or moral because they feel like
they should because whilst that might be
an important part of people's
decision-making when it comes to the
environment and protecting climate it it
should be easy because everyone needs to
make those decisions rather than just a
few people who are already passionate
about it all right we will return to
this point the stakes are very high
but even for us but already for others
they're already too real up next we'll
be speaking to a government minister
from the maldives about the threat of
climate change to the people of her
country
[Music]
so
the climate crisis
is it already too late that's our topic
on the great
debate and it's a question that's most
pressing for island nations some of
which are already facing an existential
threat
we're now joined from the global climate
conference in glasgow by the maldives
environment minister aminath shauna
good evening minister thank you for
joining us
what are you hoping for out of the next
two weeks
first of all thank you for having me
it's really great to be here what are we
looking for in this conference we want
the world to agree on 1.5 degrees we
would like all the countries to agree on
climate finance increasing climate
finance particularly for climate change
adaptation what we had agreed in paris
to release 100 billion dollars a year at
least we are also looking for countries
to agree on loss and damage these are
critical issues that are very important
for island countries like the maldives
how far are we along on that hundred
billion dollars as far as you know
the maldives is very vulnerable to
climate change we have seen we know
what's happening science is very clear
on it
since 2015 countries like the maldives
have received very little in terms of
adaptation finance the maldives has
received only one
project for climate change adaptation
what we are talking about is the impact
of climate change is real in the models
our coral reefs are dying our beaches
are eroding we are losing our islands we
have run out of water countries like the
maldives need urgent finance for these
adaptation needs but we we really
haven't received the kind of finance
that we require we need urgently to
address these things
the united nations said last week that
without some new steps new measures new
targets
the
world is unlikely to hit that 1.5 degree
target and in fact it looks more like
2.7 degrees
tell us what 2.7 degrees would mean for
the maldives
we're currently at 1.1
and what we are seeing in the maldives
is things that we were told would happen
towards the end of the century are
happening now like i said mo all the
islands in the maldives have run out of
fresh water because so coastal erosion
has increased our islands are getting
flooded more heavy rainfall when it
doesn't rain our islands run out of
water and these are real issues for us
most of the islands in the maldives are
facing urgent issues that are related to
extreme weather events
our islands are about 1200 islands
about 187 islands are inhabited and
around every island we have a coral reef
and coral reefs are very sensitive to
temperature increases when our coral
reefs die we're talking about our
survival and our food and our income are
dependent on the vulnerabilities so our
fisheries industry our tourism basically
we're talking about the maldives
becoming uninhabitable in the next
couple of decades if we fail to agree on
these targets right now
minister thank you very much indeed for
joining us
thank you
mary robinson
you heard that and you hear that again
again how typical is this of the
uh
partners at uh glasgow
it's very typical of the climate
vulnerable forum countries
they face an existential threat
and that's about climate justice uh the
elders that i have the honor to chair
feel very strongly in support of the
continuing sovereignty of each of the
pacific islands and the caribbean
islands and other island states we are
very supportive of the
measures that the climate vulnerable
forum want to see at the cup and these
measures include a climate emergency
pact
you know you talked about the 100
billion
we're not missing we're not meeting it
in 2020 or 2021 or 2022 apparently it
won't be until 2023 that we'll fully
meet but it's a six year
um promise and so it's 600 billion
dollars and in the years 23 24 and 25
we've got to make more and that's doable
absolutely by the rich world and so it's
a 600 billion it needs far more for
adaptation as it's been said by minister
shona uh it's
absolutely clear
that we need to listen to the
existential voices and get that urgency
and then have boris johnson and all the
other ministers have that crisis sense
i mean crisis sense of how to move
forward thank you let's go back to our
viewers panel and i want you um
a lot of support there for that uh
comment uh i wanna hear from david young
now
uh david i think you have a view on this
i have a really big view i'm i have two
boys who are about 20 years old and so
obviously i've got a major impact
um now obviously my question may be a
little rhetorical but it's a very
serious point i really feel that since
the industrial revolution we've got a
lot of things we've done wrong perhaps
but we are a really great big influence
in this world because of that and i
think we you know we can manufacture
a positive solution here we've got
commonwealth countries we can be part of
a green climate change revolution
so my point is
my question as a major pollution
contributor since the industrial
revolution do we have a bigger
responsibility for climate change
because of our industrial past thank you
very much david davis question is do we
have a bigger responsibility for climate
change because of our industrial past
richard walker
uh yeah i think we do
and i think some of the uh some of the
discussions that that are going on now
where where um
you know
developing nations uh countries
particularly at risk um who haven't
necessarily had the luxury of hundreds
of years of uh industrialized production
should absolutely be um be helped by the
richer world and that may mean higher
taxes for business but you know
ultimately i think it's the right thing
to do and i should also just i want to
refer back
to one of the questions before the break
um which was uh
basically on on this issue of um
democratizing environmentalism we have
to make it relevant and relatable to
real people people like my customers who
might only have 25 quid a week to spend
on food we can't be in an echo chamber
here and be preaching and i think that
goes for whether we're trying to help
developing nations around the world or
indeed people in the uk
who are on a very tight budget and we we
must
make this democratize we have to change
the subsidy systems so that um
anyone can afford to be an
environmentalist do you think other
business leaders are in the same place
as you are
um not necessarily but uh but but i do
think that uh shift is happening and
changing and even better if the
government can enforce it quicker i
think it's the right thing to do um and
i think we need to
bear responsibility uh for the plastic
that we're putting into the environment
and some of our supply chain choices so
that we can uh start to make the the
right decisions as a business community
and yes potentially that might mean
higher taxes but
i think considering the um the nature of
the emergency it's uh it's only right
okay thank you richard i come back to um
the wall i want to talk to harry
hayfield um
harry
you've been listening
what do you make of what you've heard
well i i have been listening trevor
you're absolutely correct
uh the minister from the maldives has
hit them down the head because she's
experiencing it i mean it is not that
long ago that the island nation of
banavutu
in the pacific was actually put on
warning that they could be about have to
be evacuated at any time and as we've
heard from the manager of iceland virtue
is being talked about so i have a
particular problem
and that is what is the point of this
conference when we as ordinary people
are being told to reduce our carbon
emissions to zero
and countries such as australia and
china saying yes we will indeed reduce
them but only into 50 percent of 1990
missions and not until 2050 or in 2016
or even later
thank you very much harry
ella
what is the point
well the point is to make ambitious
targets and
importantly to meet those targets
because you know it's all very well and
good making pledges but we have to
actually make sure that those pledges
are met because ultimately i mean
current
pledges are consistent with
warming of around 2.7 or perhaps more
degrees of warming and
as we've heard it's just not good enough
because we absolutely must limit warming
to not just well below two degrees but
one and a half at most because we're
seeing devastating impacts already you
have to just look at the news headlines
to see that we have to do absolutely
everything that we can and that is you
know
from business it's from these kinds of
conferences it's from world leaders but
it's also from all of us okay um mary
robinson let me put this to you
this enormous jamboree in glasgow costs
somebody a lot of money
um
that some the indian prime minister
stands up today and says we're going to
do your favor we're going to get to net
zero
by 2070
which is 20 years after the uk and by
most people's uh reckoning way too late
to make the impact that is necessary
um to quote a young sage are we getting
two weeks of blah blah blah without much
impact on the situation
first of all if i may trevor i want to
actually say i'm encouraged by each of
the questioners this evening because
they realize we're in a crisis and that
we have to take it seriously but i want
to answer your question about india i
have praised india today for that target
of meeting um a goal of net zero by 2070
india had to think very deeply about the
goal india's carbon footprint
individually is much much lower than the
rest of the world
it has come late it is a very large
poor developing country and it has to
meet its ambitions and i am praising
india for making that commitment because
i think it's real for india and it's
real that it's going renewable energy as
much as possible in difficult
circumstances etc so let's not let's not
equate um what india does and indeed
what china does and committing to 2060
with what the rich world which has
benefited so much from fossil fuel needs
to do more of and can do more of and
should do more of
you know that's really the balance that
we have common but differentiated
responsibility
well what is the best way to persuade
people to change their behavior we're
going to be talking about that
next
change is not going to come from inside
there that is not leadership this is
leadership this is
[Music]
it's a horrible thing to be doing to be
honest we don't want to be here
it's uh it's central because it's one of
the measures uh all governments can put
in place
to value carbon this essential element
in both problem and solution in climate
change if we track and measure and value
carbon
put a price on carbon which we can do a
number of different ways with regulation
or taxation or a market mechanism
if we do those things we do them across
the whole of our economy we incentivize
all of the actions that we need to take
in order to deal with the problem and we
put a price a penalty on all the actions
that we no longer want to take
which are causing risk to to us and the
planet so we've got to get it right
the idea behind article six is that you
encourage individual countries to put
their own price on carbon to choose
their own method of valuing carbon but
you also encourage other countries to
cooperate to build larger marketplaces
to create more liquidity more investment
a greater range of incentives
put together a greater response to
climate change and we need rules to do
that to do it properly
there's no value in doing something
that's illusory it actually has to do
something to solve the problem
so we have to have rules for that we
have to agree those rules and we have to
agree them amongst many parties in order
to have the largest effect the arguments
are very well rehearsed they've been
around for a very long time and we had
an earlier version of this in article 12
of the kyoto protocol which created the
clean development mechanism which which
worked which moved a lot of money
from
the developed world to the developing
world so called a lot of money moved to
china for example and which has no doubt
led to them creating their own uh carbon
market which has launched this year that
was in large part a success although
actually we didn't design the
marketplace well enough to cope with the
financial crisis
and over supply so people know about
this phenomenon they understand what it
can do
but they're obviously naturally nervous
that the market does actually deliver
environmental benefits also one of the
reasons why this agreement is so hard to
get is that there are countries like
brazil who benefited from the previous
system who believe that they might not
do so well from a new version they want
the credits from the past system to
count and they want to be sure that they
get as much as possible out of this new
marketplace and so they negotiate hard
on that front and they will need to move
in the next few days in order to get
overall agreement article 6.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back
is it already too late to tackle the
climate crisis that's a topic for
tonight's great debate
and if it isn't too late what's the best
way to get people to change
i'm going to talk to
isha gill
what's your
question for our panel tonight
hi so my question is will extinction
rebellions tactics influence government
policy and create meaningful change
have you got a particular reason for
asking that esha
uh yeah actually i um study government
and politics at school and recently
we've been looking into pressure groups
um and actually i think
extinction rebellion in particular
they raise many issues and they have a
wide support in the public sphere and
they definitely have um
raised issues that need to be raised and
the media certainly do give them a lot
of attention but you know the government
haven't really
been interested in working with them and
i think for real change to happen
uh there has to be change in government
policy and to get big corporations to
actually produce a lot of the carbon
footprint
we
we need to force them to change because
actually they're not really going to do
it on their own okay thank you sure now
it's just question then uh panel is will
extinction rebellions tactics influence
government policy and create meaningful
change let let me start with you
richard
is extinction rebellion
part of what has taken you to the
uh place that you are right now on this
set of issues
well i think they've certainly got
noticed and they've been a big part of
the the narrative um the media has
certainly given them a lot of attention
and of course they're raising uh some
very serious issues um my concern
is that to win hearts and minds uh and
ultimately
um the the will of the public is that we
have to tell people
without telling them off and we need to
reframe environmentalism to talk not
about cost and compromise but about jobs
and opportunity because i think that's
what really matters to real people on a
budget i think xr have done a great job
in terms of raising the issues however
some of the uh splinter groups such as
insulate britain um in my mind have
caused nothing but annoyance and turned
people off and the problem is um if if
you uh cajole um and harang people too
much they will simply shrug their
shoulders and look the other way uh so
so it's a it's about jobs opportunity
not cost and compromise um and i think
it that's the the tight rope and the
fine balance that we need to find okay
let's see if we can get a
a sense of what our
hundred viewers think let's go to the
wall and i'm going to ask you
without getting too much into the detail
of this splinter group or that's been
agreed or whatever it is
the direct action groups which operate
under the banner of extinction rebellion
do you think
that they have played a role in changing
the government's view in the right
direction
hands up who thinks that they have
played a role in
moving government in the right direction
i think uh it's looking to me
actually
not a majority but not zeal and there's
a few people shaking their heads
um and rather negatively about it
can ken isaacs um i can see you there
shaking your head um
why do you
think that they haven't played a
positive role
um well um well trevor i think really
that the government have acted on their
own anyway um
the
matter of protests we've seen can be
counter-productive as richard walker
said
i mean i'd like to ask chidi how he'd
feel if he was trying to get to hospital
for example for a family emergency his
path was blocked by protesters and then
the family member suddenly died why did
protesters not just peacefully protest
where they aren't going to affect
innocent people
chidi explain
i can only apologize
for inconveniences and challenges
that protest democratic protests create
to answer the question directly in may
of 2019 the uk government declared a
climate change emergency
there's no doubt in my mind that that
wouldn't have happened that early day
opposition motion parliament passed
primarily because of extinction
rebellion i know lots of execution
rebellion people all of whom you know
vicars teachers ordinary people like you
and i who want to see the world be a
better place and the uk lead the effort
in changing the world and what the
government does is the government's own
responsibility but our responsibility
has always been to state very clearly
the kinds of risks that international
agencies around the world are talking
about but our media and the uk are not
i'll give you a perfect example the ipcc
report that came out the ar-6 wg-1
report that came out on the 6th of april
august of this year led to absolutely no
falls in the prices or in the share
price of shell
led to no fall in the price of oil and
that was because everyone felt that
despite the fact that these powerful
reports are coming out governments would
not act
what accentuation like many other groups
have done is go on to continue to show
the public what is actually happening
okay
ken
are you persuaded that
on balance
what xr have done
has been
a plus rather than minus
um yes it has been a plus but the way
they've gone about it is a minus i mean
titty there is
totally not answered the thrust of the
question why not peacefully protest
instead of you getting splinter groups
blocking motorways
you know putting people at risk you know
answer the question
i'd gladly ask the question again if
you'd like me to
i i can't take responsibility for
absolutely nobody's asking because you
haven't been climbing on you haven't
been climbing on people's offices and so
on but there is a specific question here
have these tactics made the job of
persuading people
to do what you want them to do easier or
harder
in the last six months extinction
rebellion membership has grown
that's not the question
has it made the job easier or harder
it's straightforward and i think that's
because people are more persuaded i
think that because we have actually gone
out and made the case that isn't made
anywhere else in the press that there
are members of the government who are
interested there are others the public
who are persuaded we just don't have a
government that's been able to follow
right true okay let me come to you mary
robinson
um i'm not going to ask you to answer
for tactics which are specific perhaps
to the uk
but the direct action
uh tactics and so on
do you get the sense that this is what
is
pushing governments in the direction of
paying attention or are they marginal or
are they negative
i think the protests that we're seeing
the young climate activists yes
extinction rebellion and others have
definitely moved the needle of what
governments think there's no doubt about
it they are more persuaded because of
the urgency the direct voice i actually
have a different way of asking the way
in which individuals can make a
difference and that's three steps that i
call on one is to make the climate
crisis personal in your own life and you
know you've done that if you're doing
something today you weren't doing
yesterday doing something maybe more
rigorously recycling and slow fashion
changing your diet changing the way you
move around whatever then you own the
issue and it's actually good for your
mental health probably at this stage
secondly get angry and i mean angry with
those who aren't taking their
responsibility and that's what
extinction rebellion and all the others
are are you know doing very explicitly
if you like but the third thing we don't
do enough of forever we don't do enough
of this we don't imagine this world that
we need to be hurrying towards it's
going to be a much healthier world
because it won't have the fumes of
fossil fuel
um indoor and outdoor that kill about
eight or nine million people each year
mr robinson thank you let me
as we come to the end here come back to
our viewers panel tonight the queen
has called on world leaders to
achieve true statesmanship
true statementship
so let's have a show of hand from
viewers on the question that we've been
asking tonight
is it too late those who think it is
please show your throw your hands
a very uh about a third quarter a third
of you
and those who still are optimistic to
think we can turn this around
yep
that's definitely a
majority and that is an optimistic end
it's all that we have time for this
evening
though the arguments obviously are not
going to end there
it just remains for me to say thanks to
our panelists here in the studio dr ella
gilbert chidi orti obihara and from
glasgow mary robinson
and also richard walker
and i want to say thank you to all our
viewers
panel who've been as robust and
boisterous as ever and thank you waving
goodbye thank you very much
and i want to thank you at home for
watching the great debate
you